top story this memorial day a shooting
between rival motorcycle gangs that tied
up traffic for hours now it happened on
u.s 95 sunday afternoon and we're just
getting new information about this case
madison kimbrough joins us in the
newsroom with more on what she's learned
madison yeah the shooting which happened
on u.s 95 near college drive on sunday
created quite the delay for commuters as
traffic was backed up for hours seven
people were injured six taken to sunrise
hospital two of those said to be in
critical condition henderson police
confirming today that the shooting
involved members of the outlaw
motorcycle gangs hell's angels omg and
vagos omg these men identified that
you're about to see here as 66 year old
richard devries 46 year old stephen allo
and 26 year old russell smith were taken
into custody and are now facing several
charges including six counts of
attempted murder and battery now at this
time those injured have not been
identified while the suspects have been
booked into the henderson city jail it's
still unknown when their court date will
be in the newsroom madison kimbrough
live local now